"실전 양자 컴퓨팅"에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 진행자 Olivia Lanes예요. 지난 시간엔 Max-Cut이라는
최적화 문제에 대한 양자 컴퓨팅 접근법을 QUBO 공식화를 이용해서 살펴봤어요.
꽤 깊이 들어갔지만, 그건 하나의 접근법에 대한 하나의 예시였을 뿐이에요. 오늘은 근미래 응용 사례를
더 폭넓게 다루고, 유용한 양자 솔루션을 기대할 수 있는 다양한 문제 유형에 대한 직관을 키워볼 거예요.
그리고 유틸리티 규모에서 우리 커뮤니티가 이뤄낸 중요한 연구의 최근 사례들도 살펴볼게요.
이전에 잠깐 언급했듯이, 모든 문제가 추가적인 계산 능력을 필요로 하는 건 아니에요.
특히 양자 컴퓨팅이 있어야 효율적으로 풀리는 문제들이 따로 있어요. 여러분이 이미 가장 잘 아는
문제들이 있죠. 산수, 소셜 미디어 스크롤, 테트리스나 둠 같은 비디오 게임 같은 거요. 이런 건 넓게 봐서
"쉬운 문제"라고 해요. 반면에 아주 어려운 문제들도 있어요. 예를 들면 엄청나게 큰 정수의 소인수를 찾는 것처럼요.
이게 RSA 암호화의 기반이고, Shor의 알고리즘이 실제로 풀기 위해 설계된 문제예요. 또 다른
예시는 정렬되지 않은 데이터셋에서 해를 찾는 거예요. 이론적으로는 Grover 알고리즘이라는 양자 알고리즘으로
풀 수 있어요. 하지만 대부분의 전문가들은 이런 유형의 알고리즘이 오류 수정의 구현을 필요로 한다는 데 동의하고,
기술적으로 아직 거기까지는 못 갔어요. 그래서 이 수업을 진행하면서, 그리고 여러분의 양자 학습 여정에서
기억해 두세요. 우리는 바로 이 중간 어딘가에 있는 스위트 스팟을 찾고 있어요.
풀기 어려운 문제지만, 그래서 또 재미있는 거예요. 우리가 아직 많이 다루지 않은 게 하나 있는데,
계산 복잡도 이론이에요. 이유 중 하나는 좀 겁이 날 수 있어서예요. 맞아요,
복잡해요. 계산 복잡도 이론은 계산 문제를 난이도에 따라 분류하려는 컴퓨터 과학 분야예요.
고전 컴퓨팅에는 엄청나게 많은 복잡도 클래스가 있지만, 가장
기본적인 건 P 문제예요. 이건 문제의 규모가 커져도 다항식 시간 안에 풀 수 있는 문제들로,
풀기 쉽다는 의미예요. 그다음으로 더 어려운 유형이 NP 문제인데,
비결정론적 다항식의 줄임말이에요. 이건 답을 다항식 시간 안에 검증할 수는 있지만,
반드시 그 시간 안에 풀 수 있는 건 아닌 문제들이에요. 그다음은 NP-complete인데, 이제 진짜 어려운 문제들이에요.
알려진 다항식 해가 없어요. 여기에 외판원 문제나 심지어 게임인
스도쿠 같은 유명한 문제들이 속해요. 양자 컴퓨팅이 등장했을 때, 적어도 이론상으로는, 사람들이 상당한 노력을 기울여
이 새로운 유형의 컴퓨터가 효율적으로 풀 수 있는 문제 클래스가 뭔지 알아내려 했어요. 새로운 클래스의
문제들이 만들어졌는데, 경계 오류 양자 다항식 문제, 줄여서 BQP라고 해요. 정확한 정의는
좀 길지만, 작은 오류 확률로 다항식 시간 안에 양자 컴퓨터가 풀 수 있는 결정 문제 클래스예요.
오류 확률이 있는 건 양자 측정이 본질적으로 무작위이기 때문인데, 오류
확률은 임의로 작게 만들 수 있어요. 이 클래스들은 모두 PSPACE라는 더 큰 클래스 안에 있고,
BQP가 다른 문제 유형들에 비해 어디에 위치하는지는 여기 있다고 생각하는데, 수학적으로 이걸 확실히 증명하기는
매우 어려워요. BQP 양자 문제가 NP-complete 문제와 반드시 겹치지는 않는다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
하지만 NP-complete 문제를 풀려는 양자 컴퓨팅 접근법을 본 적이 있을 수도 있어요. 왜 그럴까요?
흔한 오해 중 하나는 외판원 문제 같은 문제의 해를
양자 컴퓨터나 다른 어떤 방법으로 탐색하는 게 무의미하다는 거예요. 양자 속도 향상에 대한
수학적 증명이 없는 NP-complete 문제에 대해서요. 하지만 꼭 그럴 필요는 없어요.
양자 알고리즘이 고전 알고리즘보다 빠르다는 수학적 증명을 찾는 건 드문 일이에요. Shor과
Grover는 지금까지 그게 이루어진 몇 안 되는 예시 중 하나예요. 하지만 그래도 괜찮아요. 사실 컴퓨터
과학자들도 P와 NP 클래스가 다르다는 걸 아직 증명하지 못했어요. 모든 직관이
그래야 한다고 말하는데도요. 또한 두 알고리즘을 비교할 때 스케일링을 보면 보통 최악의 경우
시나리오를 봐요. 실제로는 최악의 경우가 현실에서 나타나지 않을 수도 있어요. 그래서
절망하지 말고, 대신 휴리스틱 솔루션이라는 개념을 소개할게요. 실험가라면
이미 이런 유형의 솔루션을 잘 알고 좋아할 거예요. 휴리스틱이란 문제를
실용적이지만 반드시 최적은 아닌 방식으로 푸는 접근법이에요. 그래도 괜찮아요. 솔루션이 반드시
최적일 필요는 없으니까요. 아주 유용할 수 있거든요. 예를 들어 금융 응용을 생각해 봐요. 양자가 쓰일 수 있는
대부분의 금융 알고리즘에서 지수적 속도 향상은 아직 찾지 못했어요. 하지만 꼭 그게 중요한 건 아니에요. 최적 솔루션이 필요하지 않아요.
적어도 금융에서는요. 단 1%만 더 효율적인 솔루션이라도 수십억 달러의
이익과 맞먹을 수 있거든요. 그렇다면 지금 당장 양자 컴퓨팅에 적합할 수 있는 유스케이스와 문제가 뭔지 어떻게 알 수 있을까요?
지금 또는 가까운 미래에 양자 유틸리티나 심지어 양자 우위를 찾을 수 있다고 믿을 만한 충분한 이유가 있다는 의미에서요.
문제가 확실히 가지면 안 될 것들을 먼저 꼽는 게 더 쉬울 수도 있어요.
엄청난 수의 qubit이 필요하면 안 돼요. 수천에서 수백만 개의 qubit을 가진 프로세서는 아직 없어요. 이게
Shor 알고리즘 같은 게 아직 먼 이유 중 하나예요. circuit도 엄청 깊으면 안 돼요. 정확히 어떤
circuit 깊이가 안 되는지 말하기 어려운 건 너무 많은 요인에 달려 있어서예요. 하지만 일반적으로
실험에서 문헌에서 아직 본 적 없는 깊이가 필요하다면, 힘든 시간을 보낼 수 있어요.
마지막으로, 오류 수정이 필요한 알고리즘은 아직 할 수 없어요. 그러나 우리가 찾아야 할 건 주어진 QPU에서 사용 가능한 qubit을 최대한 활용하는 실험들이에요.
우리는 또 오류 완화와 억제의 중요성을 강조했고, 마지막으로 미래
응용으로의 명확한 확장이 있어야 해요. 사회에 중요하고 결국에는 양자
우위로 이어질 수 있다고 볼 수 있는 것이요. 이제 세 가지 주요 카테고리에 속하는 유스케이스 예시들을 얘기해 볼게요.
우리가 근미래에서 중기에 걸쳐 좋은 결과를 볼 가능성이 높다고
파악한 세 가지 주요 카테고리예요.
첫 번째 분야는 자연의 시뮬레이션이에요. 전에도 얘기했지만, 분자 및 원자 수준에서
이루어지는 연구를 양자 컴퓨터가 향상시킬 수 있는 기회가 정말 많아요.
이유는 현재 고전적인 방법이 원자 구조에 대한 근본적으로 비효율적인 수학적
표현에 의해 제한되어 있기 때문이에요. 양자 상태를 저장하고 조작하는 데는 지수적인 양의 자원이 필요한데,
고전 컴퓨터에서는요. 하지만 양자 컴퓨터에서는 효율적으로 할 수 있어요. 그래서 재료 시뮬레이션과
화학 모델링이 가장 유망한 응용 분야 중 하나예요. 더 구체적으로는, 이게
이산화탄소 격리, 대체 배터리, 또는 새로운 약물 발명으로 이어질 수 있어요. 이 분야에서 특히 관련된
알고리즘으로는 변분 양자 고유값 솔버 VQE가 있는데, 평형 상태나 최소 에너지 상태 같은
재료의 특성을 추정하는 데 쓰여요. 또 다른 예시는
시간 동역학 시뮬레이션 TDS인데, 이 알고리즘은 재료의 응답 함수나 스펙트럼 특성을 추정하는 데 쓰여요.
그리고 새로 나온 것도 언급하고 싶은데, 샘플 기반 양자 대각화예요. 가까운 미래에 훨씬 많이
듣게 될 거라고 생각해요. 다음 응용 분야는 최적화예요. 최적화는 컴퓨팅에서 꽤 널리 퍼져 있어서
유스케이스가 상당히 많고 다양해요.
자주 듣는 예시로는 금융의 포트폴리오 최적화, 산업 설계, 그리고
유통 및 공급망이 있어요. 최적화와 관련해서 아마 가장 많이 들어볼 알고리즘은 우리가 이미
어느 정도 깊이 다룬 양자 근사 최적화 알고리즘,
즉 QAOA예요. 마지막으로, 최근 몇 년간 굉장히 화제가 된 분야가 양자 머신 러닝이에요.
QML이 시뮬레이션만큼 빨리 실현되기는 어려울 것 같다고 말하는 게 공정할 것 같지만, 그래도
사람들이 꾸준히 연구하고 있는 인상적인 알고리즘들이 있고, 매우 중요한 유스케이스와
연결되어 있어요. 가능한 유스케이스로는 자연어 처리, 네트워크 트래픽 분석, 심지어 금융 거래에서의
사기 탐지가 있어요. 이 분야의 관련 알고리즘으로는 양자 서포트 벡터
머신, 양자 신경망, 그리고 양자 생성적 적대 신경망이 있어요. 방금 설명한 세 가지
그룹은 넓은 응용 분야예요. 커뮤니티에서 특정 주제에 집중하는 그룹들이
함께 협력하는 것도 도움이 된다는 걸 언급할 가치가 있어요. IBM이 얼마 전
워킹 그룹이라는 이니셔티브를 주도했는데, 협력자들이 만나고 네 가지 특정 분야에서 생산적인 시너지를 만들 수 있도록 돕기 위한 거예요.
그 분야는 헬스케어 및 생명과학, 재료 및 HPC, 고에너지 물리학, 그리고
최적화예요. 현재 그룹과 참여 기관들이 여기 있어요. 워킹 그룹이 하는 일에 대해 더 듣고 싶다면,
아래 설명에 네 개의 백서를 첨부해 뒀어요. 앞서 말했듯이,
이 시점에서 가장 좋은 건 사람들이 이 기술의 최첨단에서 어떤 문제를 연구하고 있는지 살펴보고,
어떤 유형의 알고리즘이 효과를 발휘하고 어떻게 적용하는지에 대한 직관을 키우는 거예요.
시작하기 전에, 여기서 주요 목표가 실험의 모든 세부 사항을 이해하는 게 아니라는 걸 분명히 말해두고 싶어요.
논문이 자신의 전문 분야와 약간 다르면 전문가들도 이런 분석이 아주 어려울 수 있어요.
목표는 단순히 양자 컴퓨터가 어떤 유형의 문제에 적합하고 어떻게 다루는지에 대한 직관을 키우는 거예요.
세부 사항에 관심이 있고 이게 자신만의 아이디어를 자극했다면, 전체 논문을 직접 읽어보길 꼭 권해요.
우리가 심층적으로 살펴볼 구체적인 유스케이스와 논문들은 이것들이에요. 먼저 하드론 동역학 시뮬레이션을 다루는 논문을 살펴볼 거예요.
이건 고에너지 물리학 카테고리에 속해요. 다음으로 최적화 문제, 구체적으로는
바이어스 필드 반단열 양자 최적화를 살펴볼 거예요. 마지막으로 또 다른 시뮬레이션 문제를 볼 텐데,
이번에는 mRNA에 집중해요. 약물 및 치료제 개발에 핵심적인 분자예요.
이 논문들에 익숙하든 아니든 괜찮아요. 같이 살펴볼 거예요.
세 편 모두 상당한 규모의 문제를 다루고 양자 컴퓨터가 또 다른 과학적 탐구 방법으로 어떻게 사용되기 시작했는지를 보여주는 중요한 논문들이에요.
첫 번째는 하드론 동역학 시뮬레이션이에요.
University of Washington의 Martin Savage 그룹이 쓴 논문인데, 제목은 "112
qubit을 이용한 Schwinger 모델에서의 하드론 동역학 양자 시뮬레이션"이에요.
고에너지 물리학자가 아니더라도 Large Hadron Collider,
즉 LHC처럼 하드론이라는 용어는 들어봤을 거예요. LHC는 둘레가 27킬로미터에 달하는 거대한 입자 가속기로,
마침내 힉스 보손을 관측하는 걸 가능하게 했어요. 하드론은 쿼크라고 불리는
더 작은 입자들로 이루어진 아원자 복합 입자예요. 예시로는 중성자와 양성자가 있어요. 맥락을 좀 드리자면, LHC는
기초 물리학 연구와 입자들이 초고에너지로 충돌할 때 무슨 일이 일어나는지 연구하기 위해 만들어졌어요.
이 원형 튜브 안에서요. 이를 통해 과학자들은 초기 우주가 어떻게 탄생했는지 더 많이 알게 되길 바라고 있어요.
그리고 앞서 말했듯이, 질량을 담당하는 포착하기 어려운 입자인 보손을 찾는 데도 쓰였어요.
기본 입자들의 질량을 담당하는 보손이요. 이제 원칙적으로 이 입자들의 상호작용은
충분히 강력한 양자 컴퓨터로 처음부터 끝까지 시뮬레이션할 수 있어요. 아직 거기까지는 아니지만, 발전이
이루어지고 있어요. Schwinger 모델은 이런 동역학 중 일부를 시뮬레이션하는 데 사용되는 간단한 모델로, 가장
인기 있는 선택 모델 중 하나로 자리 잡았어요. 모델의 세부 사항은 지금 당장은 그렇게 중요하지 않지만, 궁금한 분들을 위해 말씀드리면
이건 1+1 차원에서 광자를 통해 상호작용하는 전자와 양전자의 거동을 설명하는 모델이에요.
공간 차원이 하나이고 시간이 있다는 의미예요. 이 모델은 쿼크와 하드론이 상호작용하는 방식을 설명하는 양자
색역학과 많은 유사점이 있어요. 그건 시뮬레이션하기가 극도로 어려워서
Schwinger 모델이 두 이론에서 공통적으로 나타나는 일부 현상을 탐구하는 장난감 모델로 자주 쓰여요.
이 예시와 나머지 예시들을 살펴보는 방법은
일련의 질문을 스스로에게 해보는 거예요. 첫 번째는, 왜 이걸
양자 컴퓨터에서 시뮬레이션하면 효과가 있을 거라고 믿을 이유가 있었냐는 거예요.
이 경우, Schwinger 모델에서 전자와 양전자는 차폐 효과를 가지고 있어서 멀리 떨어진 페르미온 사이의
상관관계가 거리에 따라 지수적으로 감소해요. 이는
칩 한쪽 qubit에서 다른 쪽 qubit으로의 장거리 상호작용이 많지 않다는 의미예요.
그게 오류가 매우 발생하기 쉽다는 걸 알기 때문에, 오늘날 사용 가능한 하드웨어에 정말 적합해요. 다음은
이 주제가 과연 관심을 받을 만한가 하는 거예요. 고에너지 물리학이 매우 중요하다고
이미 어느 정도 납득시킨 것 같지만, LHC를 짓는 데 수십억 달러를 쓸 의향이 있었고, 전 세계 수천 명의 과학자와
기술자들이 이 분야에 인생을 바쳤어요. 그만큼 중요하니까요. 하지만
Schwinger 모델은 단순하고 세 개의 공간 차원을 다루도록 설계된 건 아니에요. 그래도
현재 검증 가능한 단면들을 제공하고 완전한 이론의 유용한 단순화를 제공하는 중요한 모델이에요.
마지막으로, 이 연구가 어떻게 수행되었는지, 또는 시뮬레이션 유형의 실험에서 연구를 계속하려 한다면 어떤 접근법을 사용할지예요.
VQE가 가장 흔한 접근법 중 하나이고, 첫 번째 단계는 거의 항상 같아요.
바닥 상태를 준비하는 거예요. 이 경우 진공 상태예요. 이 실험에서는 SC-adapt VQE라는 새 버전의 VQE를 사용해서
진공 위에 바닥 상태와 하드론 파속을 모두 준비해요. 다음 단계는
하드론이 시간에 따라 진화하거나 전파되도록 하는 거예요. 마지막으로, 감지하고 싶은
관측 가능량을 확인해야 해요. 하드론 파속 부분을 빼면 이 단계들이 좀 익숙하게 들린다면,
이전 에피소드에서 QAOA 예시에서 다룬 것과 매우 유사하기 때문이에요.
여기서 패턴이 보이기 시작하길 바라요. VQE에 필요한 구성 요소들은 QAOA와 매우 유사해요.
익숙한 상태, 여기서는 진공 상태에서 시작해서 일련의 지수화된
해밀토니안으로 관리 가능한 덩어리로 나눠서 시간에 따라 진화시켜요. n은 분할 수예요. 여기서 큰 차이는
진화를 시작하기 전에 circuit 안에 하드론의 파속을 중앙에 만든다는 거예요. 그럼 어떻게 하냐면,
진공 상태가 바닥 상태이고 이걸 매핑하는 방법은 이미 어느 정도 다뤘어요. 이제 하드론
파속 준비는 약간 달라요. 이 진공 위에서 하드론은 인접한 위치에 페르미온-반페르미온 쌍을 만들어서 들뜨게 할 수 있어요.
다른 위치에 이런 하드론들의 중첩을 준비함으로써 임의의 파속을
준비할 수 있어요. 저자들은 경계를 초과하지 않고 진화를 관찰하기 위해 circuit 중앙에 파속을 놓았어요.
하지만 잡음이 있는 QPU로 작업할 때 중요한 건 circuit
깊이를 관리 가능하게 유지하는 거예요. 이를 위해 SC-adapt VQE 프로토콜은 대칭과
길이 스케일의 계층을 사용해서 상태 준비를 위한 얕은 깊이의 양자 circuit을 결정해요. 아이디어는
더 적은 매개변수로 앙상블을 만들어서 더 얕은 깊이와 같게 한다는 거예요. 더 많은 세부 사항은
여기서 다룰 시간보다 논문에서 더 자세히 찾을 수 있으니까 꼭 확인해 보세요. 이제 결과를 살펴볼게요. 이 실험은
IBM Quantum Heron 장치에서 실행됐고, 몇 가지 다른 유형의 오류 완화와 억제를 구현했어요.
연산자 디코히어런스 재정규화라는 더 최근의 기법을 포함해서 동적 디커플링, 영잡음
외삽, 폴리 트월링도 사용했어요. 이제 데이터를 해석해 봐요. 파속이 어떻게 전파되는지 관찰하기 위해
실제로 측정할 관측 가능량은 카이랄 응축이라는 거예요. 좀 추상적이지만,
기본적으로 하드론의 초유체 위상이에요. 이 실험을 실행하도록 지정된 위치에 파속이 중앙에 있는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
색상은 카이랄 응축에 해당해요.
왼쪽은 시뮬레이터의 오류 없는 결과를 보여주고, 오른쪽은 IBM 양자
컴퓨터 Torino의 결과를 보여줘요. 이상적으로는 대칭으로 인해 서로 거울 이미지여야 하는데, 약간의 불완전함이 있는 게 보여요.
이 수직 y축은 앞서 측정한 시간 덩어리에 해당해요.
데이터의 첫 번째와 마지막 시간 단계에서 수평 단면을 취해서 파속에 무슨 일이 일어나는지 봐요.
t=1에서, 오렌지색으로 이 단면에 해당하는 부분에서
카이랄 응축이 좁고 국소화되어 있는 걸 볼 수 있어요. t=14에서의 비교 시뮬레이션과도 잘 일치해요.
하지만 t=14에서는 훨씬 더 퍼져 있고 국소화가 덜 돼요.
시뮬레이터와의 비교가 지금은 완벽하지 않을 수 있지만, 이론과 데이터 사이에 여전히 매우 좋은 일치를 볼 수 있어서 고무적이에요.
결론적으로, 처음에는 양자 컴퓨터를 적용할 생각을 못 했을 수도 있는 시뮬레이션 연구의 멋진 예시예요.
하지만 실제로 할 수 있고, 효과가 있어요. 완벽하지는 않지만, 입자 물리학 전문가가 아니어도
양자 컴퓨터가 파속의 외부 전파를 정확하게 예측한다는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
이게 우리가 기대하는 결과예요. 앞으로 이 분야의 연구가 계속되고 고에너지 물리학자들이
양자 컴퓨팅을 연구 흐름에 통합하는 방법을 계속 찾길 바라요. 목표는 이론적 문제를 더 정밀하게,
고전적으로 할 수 없는 방식으로 풀고, 실험을 이용해서 이론을 수용하거나 기각해서 새로운
물리학을 발견하고, 더 나은 검출기를 만들고, 가장 근본적인 수준에서 자연을 더 잘 이해하는 거예요.
다음 예시는 최적화에 초점을 맞추고, "바이어스 필드
디지털화 반단열 양자 최적화"라는 논문을 깊이 살펴볼 거예요. Kipu Quantum 팀과
스페인 바스크 컨트리 대학교 구성원들이 쓴 거예요. 전처럼
일련의 정의부터 시작할게요. 첫 번째는 반단열인데, 이건 그 과정이 얼마나 빨리 일어나든 관계없이 시스템이 경험하는 비단열 효과를 억제하는 진화 유형이에요.
지난 에피소드에서 단열 정리를 기억해 보세요. 시스템이 바닥 상태에 머물길 원한다면
보통 매우 천천히 진화하게 해야 해요.
이건 큰 문제예요. 진화를 천천히 할수록 오류가 발생할 시간이
더 많아지니까요. 반단열 구동, 흔히 CD로 줄여서 쓰는데, 이런 원하지 않는 들뜸을 상쇄하는 항을
추가해서 이를 극복하려 해요. 여기서 핵심 아이디어는 전체 실험 속도를 높이고
거짓 전이로 이어질 수 있는 들뜸을 억제해서 양자 circuit 깊이를 줄이는 거예요.
이제 바이어스 필드가 뭔지 얘기해 볼게요. VQE 같은 다른 반복 알고리즘은 고전 매개변수를
이런 상태에 넣고 고전 최적화기를 사용해서 고정된 해밀토니안에 대한 최솟값 기댓값을 내는
매개변수 집합을 찾으려 다차원 매개변수 공간을 탐색해요. 이 경우에는 대신에 각 반복마다 해밀토니안을 변경해요.
알려진 경우에서 관심 있는 경우로 단열적으로 이동해요. 하지만 전달되는 고전 매개변수가 없고
변분 파동 함수도 없으면, 한 번의 해밀토니안 통과에서 다음 번으로 어떻게 상태를 업데이트하냐고요?
그래서 해밀토니안에 바이어스 필드를 추가해요. 이전 실행에서 나온 최저 에너지 상태가 무엇이든, 그 상태를 선호하는 방향으로
해밀토니안에 항을 추가해요. 그럼 왜 이 실험이 관심을 받을 만하냐면,
우선 이건 다른 최적화 문제에 더 일반적으로 적용할 수 있는 새로운 접근법이에요.
하지만 이 경우에는 이징 스핀 글래스 문제에 적용했어요. 앞서 논의했듯이, 많은 조합 최적화
문제들을 이징 해밀토니안의 저에너지 상태를 구하는 문제로 재구성할 수 있어요.
이징 모델은 배열에 분포된 미시적 스핀의 집합이에요. 이 모델은 자화가 무질서한 스핀 글래스를 설명하는 데 쓸 수 있는데,
기본적으로 작은 자기 모멘트들이 배열에서 무작위로 방향이 정해져 있어요.
왜 이게 효과가 있을 거라고 생각했냐면, 논문 정의를 다루면서 변분 알고리즘에서 발견되는 두 가지 전형적인 문제를 어떻게 극복하는지
어느 정도 이미 다뤘어요. 요약하자면, 그들이 제안하는 알고리즘은 진화를 가속해서 circuit 깊이를 줄이면서
비단열 전이도 억제해요.
게다가 베런 고원과 지역 최솟값에 갇히는 문제를 일으킬 수 있는 고전 최적화 루틴에 의존하지 않아요.
마지막으로, 저자들은 또한 문제 해밀토니안의 상호작용을 실제 QPU의 하드웨어 연결성과 일치시켜요.
이건 항상 매우 중요해요. 마지막으로, 이게 어떻게 작동하냐면, 앞서 말했듯이 반복 양자 알고리즘에서 자주 사용하는 것과 달리
여기서는 고전 최적화기가 사용되지 않아요.
대신 각 반복의 솔루션을 다음 반복의 입력으로 공급함으로써, 바이어스 필드 디지털화
양자 최적화 알고리즘은 바닥 상태를 점진적으로 정제해서 최종 진화 상태에
점점 더 가까이 가져가요. 그리고 반단열 프로토콜과 결합하면, 잡음이 있는 하드웨어에서도 원활하게 실행될 수 있는
짧은 깊이의 양자 circuit으로 이걸 할 수 있어요. 실험을 수행할 때, 저자들은
127 qubit IBM 양자 컴퓨터 Brisbane에서 알고리즘을 실행하기로 했어요.
여기서 저자들은 최근접 이웃으로 무작위 생성된 스핀 글래스 인스턴스에 대한 최적화 알고리즘의 단열화를 보여줬어요.
100 qubit 이상이에요. DCQ와 BF-DCQ의 이상적인 시뮬레이션 결과를 비교하고,
실험 결과도 보여주며, GOOBI라는 고전 솔버의 결과도 참조로 보여줘요.
단 10번의 반복만으로 BF-DCQ는 DCQ에 비해 엄청난 향상을 보여줘요.
실험 결과가 잡음으로 인해 이상적인 결과와 약간 다르지만, 성능은 여전히
이상적인 DCQ보다 좋아요. 이건 양자 최적화 분야에서 여전히 훌륭한 발전이 이루어지고 있고,
처음으로 100 qubit 이상에서 좋은 결과가 보고되고 있다는 걸 보여줘요.
마지막으로, Moderna Pharmaceuticals의 친구들이 mRNA 구조 예측을 탐구하는 매우 흥미로운 논문이 있어요.
제목은 "유틸리티 규모 양자 컴퓨터를 이용한 mRNA 2차 구조 예측"이에요.
시작하기 전에, 저처럼 생물학 수업을 몇 년째 안 들었다면 mRNA가 뭔지 복습할 수 있어요.
메신저 RNA는 단백질 합성에 관여하는 RNA의 한 종류예요.
기본적으로 DNA가 주는 지침을 읽어요. mRNA의 2차 구조는 쉽게 말해서 사슬이 어떻게 접히는지예요.
RNA 2차 구조 예측 문제는 DNA와 RNA를 이루는 뉴클레오타이드 염기 서열의
가장 안정적인 폴딩을 찾는 문제예요. C, G, U, A 이것들이에요.
이 이미지는 mRNA에서 발견되는 일반적인 폴딩 구조 중 일부를 보여줘요. 각 색상은 서로
다른 2차 구조를 나타내는데, 어떤 특성이 한 구조를 다른 구조보다 더 유리하게 만드는지는
잘 이해되지 않아요. 우리가 할 수 있는 건 어떤 구조가 비접힌 상태에 비해 자유 에너지가 가장 낮은지 알아내는 거예요.
그리고 여기서 양자 컴퓨터가 등장해요. mRNA 2차 구조가 왜 중요하냐면,
정확한 예측이 DNA와 유전자 이해뿐 아니라
코로나19 백신 같은 RNA 기반 치료제 설계에도 실제로 중요해요. 이 논문의 접근법이
효과가 있을 거라고 믿을 이유가 있는데, 이건 오래전부터 고전
컴퓨터에게는 엄청난 최적화 문제로 알려져 왔어요. 가능한 구성이 방대하고, 일부 구성의 경우 실제로
NP-complete 문제로 알려져 있어요. 하지만 양자 컴퓨터에서는 2차 구조 예측을
이진 최적화 문제로 공식화할 수 있어요. 우리가 다루는 방법을 아는 문제예요. 게다가 소규모 양자 장치와 양자 시뮬레이터에서
정확한 RNA 예측에 대한 증거가 이미 문헌에 있어요. 그러니 명확한 질문은
더 큰 하드웨어에서도 효과가 있을 거냐는 거예요. 실험은 조건부 위험 가치
변분 양자 고유값 솔버를 사용해서 수행됐어요. 기존 VQE 알고리즘의 변형으로
더 나은 수렴을 달성할 것으로 기대돼요. 이 그래프는 42개
뉴클레오타이드 80 qubit 인스턴스에 대해 해당 에너지를 가진 샘플 비트 스트링의
측정 확률 분포를 보여줘요. 여기서 비트 스트링은 뉴클레오타이드의 쌍을 나타내요.
최저 에너지 비트 스트링이 -140의 에너지 값을 가지는 걸 보여주는데, 이건 비교 고전 솔버가 찾은 최저
에너지 비트 스트링과 일치해요. 정말 좋은 결과예요. 그리고 이게 최저 에너지 비트 스트링을 기반으로 한 뉴클레오타이드 사슬의 최적 폴딩 구조예요.
하드웨어가 찾아낸 거예요.
이제 이 에피소드의 마무리에 이르렀어요. 여기서 제 목표는 여러 연구 논문의 세부 사항으로 여러분을 압도하려는 게 아니었어요.
앞서 말했듯이, 단순히 지금 이 분야의 최첨단 연구가 어떻게 생겼는지 이해할 만한 맥락을 드리고 싶었어요.
이게 모두의 머릿속에서 생각의 톱니바퀴를 돌리고, 다른 사람들이 문제에 어떻게 접근하는지를 봄으로써
연결 고리를 만들고, 이전에는 시도하지 않았을 새로운 양자 실험을 시도할 자신감을 갖게 되길 바라요.
그중 일부가 성과를 못 낼 수도 있고, 그건 괜찮아요. 그래서 이게 연구인 거예요.
앞으로 나아가면서, 우리가 관심 있는 문제 유형은 방법론 또는 주제에 따라 그룹화할 수 있고,
가장 유망하다고 생각하는 것들을 정리해 뒀어요.
단기적으로 가장 유망한 것들이에요. 양자 컴퓨팅이 모든 것에 좋은 건 아니라는 걸 기억해요. 솔직히 이건 우리가 고전
컴퓨팅을 얼마나 잘하게 됐는지를 보여주는 증거예요. 어떤 문제에 양자 컴퓨팅을 적용할 수 있다고 생각한다고 해서
흥미로운 결과를 낼 거라는 의미는 아니에요. 안타깝게도 스케일링을 고려해야 해요. circuit
깊이는 양날의 검이에요. 고전 컴퓨터가 할 수 없는 흥미로운 작업을 하려면 상당히 커야 하지만,
지금은 하드웨어 잡음 때문에 엄청 크게 밀어붙일 수가 없어요. 피델리티가
떨어질 테니까요. 전부 그 스위트 스팟을 찾는 것이고, 그게 움직이는 목표라는 걸 아는 거예요. 그러니
지금과 다음 에피소드 사이에 시간을 내서 여러분이 접해 온 문제들과 지금까지 배운 것으로 어떻게
접근할지 진지하게 생각해 보세요. 창의적으로 생각하고 스스로를 제한하지 마세요. 아이디어가 있다면, 좀 엉뚱하다 싶어도
아래 댓글에 알려주세요. 시청해 주셔서 감사해요. 다음 시간에 봬요!